[ Laughter ]
-That is a funny one.
That was a funny one.
Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
It is time to play "Password"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Our first team tonight --
she stars in the new
Netflix movie "6 Balloons,"
and he is an award-winning
rapper and producer.
It's Abbi Jacobson
and ASAP Rocky!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Their opponents --
from the legendary Roots crew,
it is Tariq and Questlove!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
And the rules of the game
are very, very simple.
I will give
each of you a password,
then you are going to
give a one-word clue
that is one word only
to your partner
to see if they can
guess the password.
The team with the most points
after four words wins.
The first clue goes
to Abbi and Questlove.
-The password is...
[ Laughter ]
-Don't look, Tariq.
Abbi?
-I go first?
-Why don't you start us off?
Yeah, absolutely.
-Okay.
-All right.
-Yep. Right.
Oh, they're getting in there.
-[ As Rihanna ]
♪♪ Diamonds ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-I don't know, man.
That's over.
-Why did you say it like that?
[ Laughter ]
Rihanna.
-Oh, my gosh! Come on!
That was great!
Oh, my goodness!
Give me that.
Didn't even get a chance, man.
All right. I'm gonna give the
next clue to Rocky and Tariq.
Here you go. Best of luck.
-The password is...
-Tariq?
Tariq, you are up first.
-All right. Okay.
Stuffed.
-Dumpling?
-Yes!
♪♪♪♪
-That was good!
"Stuffed" was the jam!
-That was good.
-...Wu-Tang reference...
-Sorry about that.
That was good stuff.
Oh, man. All right. Here we go.
Abbi, Questlove,
these next clues are for you.
-The password is...
-Questlove, why don't you
start us off this time?
Since you didn't have
a chance to go.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Philly...
-East Point.
-Suburbs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's it! That's it!
-Oh, wow!
No, it's not it.
-I got it, I got it, I got it.
-"Suburbs." Yeah.
Judges, can we accept?
No, of course we can't. Yeah.
[ Buzzer ]
Okay.
-Um...
Thing?
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Philly. Thing.
-Cheesesteak.
I agree.
-Slang.
-Jawn.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Jawn.
-Aww! I would've known...
-I would have said "jam."
All right. Here we go.
Our final clue goes to
Rocky and Tariq right there.
Here you go.
-The password is...
-ASAP, why don't you
start us off?
Here we go.
Oh, eye contact has begun.
They're in the zone.
Auto Zone.
-Fangs.
-Fangs?
-Oh. Fangs.
Vampire.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-[ Transylvanian accent ]
Blood!
[ Laughter ]
-He's pointing again.
-Blood? Oh! Dracula.
-Yes!
-You got it!
♪♪♪♪
They're like --
They grew up together.
The champs -- Questlove and
Tariq right there, everybody!
That was well done.
You were great. That was great.
Our thanks to Abbi Jacobson,
ASAP Rocky, Tariq, Questlove.